Visuospatial reasoning is reasoning with visuospatial knowledge.
This has two parts to it, visual and spatial. Visual deals with the what part.
Spatial deals with the where part. So imagine a picture in
which there is a sun on the top right of the picture. There are two parts to it.
Sun, the what, the object. And where, the top right of the picture.
We have come across visuospatial reasoning a little bit when we use
constraint propagation to do line labeling and 2D images. One way of defining
visuospatial knowledge is to say that in visuospatial knowledge causality is,
at most, implicit. Imagine a picture in which there is a cup with
a pool of water around it. You don't know where the pool of water came from.
But you and I can quickly infer that the cup must have contained the water, and
the water must have spilled out as the cup fell. So visuospatial knowledge,
causality is implicit when it enables inferences about causality.